comment écrire y est vous s'inquiètent
matin avec des tirettes s'en tirer avec
un nappage trophée après le des ou
plutôt eu ici pour guy matin autre
exemple fameux docteur selon que l'on
mette un trait d'union ou pas et elle la
femme du médecin ou une femme médecin
femme dort terre c'est la femme qui est
docteur et c'est la femme du docteur
premiers à adopter
là ce sont des questions comme celle là
qui ont alimenté ce matin les
changements organisé par le liant nage
pour langue créole matinik des
associations qui souhaitent une
meilleure harmonisation du créole avec
des règles d'orthographe et de syntaxe
unique fait des bonds comptage ou non
effectivement trouver des consensus en
classe i clarifier la gloire parce que
chaque ménage gagnant les matches
différents les seuls à parler du trident
du fouladou
chaque poignet manager a bouclé ses
outils ya donc aujourd'hui en place il
fait qu'on s'est fait fait 90 des nanas
balang la phase là bas une codification
trop importante de la langue
pourrait-elle avoir l'effet inverse et
décourager ceux qui considéraient alors
ne pas savoir correctement parler créole
il ya de l'argot il y a des
il y a des comment dire ça il y à des
niveaux de nombreux amis me vouland dit
aussi le cas et qu'il fasse et il n'y
aurait pu effacer jusqu'à jeudi genou
craquer la langue français rappelle
d'assez longue avec une époque qui
maniait donc justement aussi est fondée
ni faudrait l'année ankama et qu'elle
loue à toi ni de ces rencontres devrait
se dégager des pistes de réflexion et
des propositions qui devront
nécessairement convaincre le plus grand
nombre pour une adoption pérenne est
unanime